bob's in sacramento hey bob welcome to
the ramsey show
hi there uh scenario is
i've done everything wrong according to
you dave
thank you for your honesty bob i'm sorry
my wife and i
have a mortgage on our home of about 550
000 we also lost the home
in august to the wildfires oh
no i'm so sorry i'm sorry we had just
refinanced
from a 3.5
to a 2.75 in may
i got another call from the mortgage
company in november and said would you
like to
lower that to 2.25
and i said can you finance air and they
said yes
so i took the 2.25 loan
i have enough capital that i could pay
off the loan
the only problem is the price of two
befores has
doubled and with the insurance
settlement i don't know how much home i
can build
if i pay off the loan so i need
for your wise advice so what will they
give you for the burned house
uh as much as
902 000 okay what is the lot worth uh
four hundred thousand okay
all right do you and do you get the lot
i mean okay
no yeah you get you get 902 from the
mortgage company you pay off 550
and you get the lot but 902
is the absolute max with everything yeah
furnishings and everything
uh no that's just the house director
okay that would be all the extra add-ons
that the state of california has added
such as sprinklers
solar and an electric vehicle water
charging station and any cost overruns
above the policy
okay so will they write you a check
for can you talk them up or you're in
your attorney get them to give you a
check for 900 000
you pay and you pay off the mortgage out
of that i'm afraid not i have the cash
on hand that i could pay it no that's
not what i'm asking i'm trying to figure
out how much money you can get out of
this freaking insurance company and walk
away
uh probably
hmm i'm not sure
let's make up another number okay i'm
going to call it 800.
okay okay for example purposes you got
to pay off a 550 000
mortgage and so that leaves you uh
250 000 and you have a 400 000
lot that you sell for 400 000 scrape it
and sell it
okay now you've got
650 000 in your pocket plus the money
that you already told me you had to pay
off the house with
you've got other capital right correct
yes and it amounts to how much
uh approximately
four hundred thousand okay so now you've
got a million dollars to buy a house
with
and i would buy a used house i wouldn't
try to build right now
building my wife and i are still
debating about the politics of
california we'd like to find somewhat
someplace a little more sane yeah well a
million dollars will buy a lot more
other places in sacramento sacramento is
a wonderful town i like sacramento
but it is an expensive real estate
market yes um and if you move it's not
it's not
it's not orange county uh silicon valley
expensive but it's expensive
and so uh it is california expensive you
know so
i mean if you said we wanted to move to
xy state
now a million dollars going to buy a lot
more and this is your escape route
you don't build you don't rebuild here
have you got any wise words that i could
use to convince my better half
about leaving california or about
rebuilding both
number one rebuilding's not going to
make sense
because it's the worst possible time to
buy two befores
and uh steel and copper
and plywood there's a shortage on all of
it right now and it's all doubled and in
some cases tripled
and so you're gonna have trouble you're
going to have a lot of trouble putting
back a house
even the size that you had before you're
going to come out
hundreds of thousands of dollars ahead
not
building
okay because of the because the building
cost right now
yes you know it's uh if you want to
build a house it's okay right now but
this is
you know but but if you can avoid
building one right now i would
i would wait a year or maybe two if you
really really really want to build
and there's nothing tying you to this
lot
scrape it and sell it okay now you got
now you got a million dollars piled up
and then you can buy in sacramento or
you can leave california that's a
separate decision than whether to build
on this lot
yes two different decisions you can make
both of them
you can make a decision to leave
california or stay in california but
i'm scraping this lot and selling it for
400 grand or 500 grand somebody'll
probably buy it because there's a
shortage
and um you know you may get great price
on a silly thing
and get and you know and
here's the thing other thing that's
going through my head and i need to say
it out loud
one of the top 10 things that'll put you
in the hospital is
losing a home to a fire it is highly
emotional
it's like a death yes
i mean i've gone through the stages dave
yeah you go through the grieving stages
as if you
you know you know and so it's you know
bankruptcy
divorce house fire loss of a child
these are the top 10 things you know you
get two or three of them in one year
you're in the hospital
i mean it'll take you out it's a it's
highly traumatic
and what i'm trying to do also is give
your emotions some
uh margin rebuilding a house building a
house is freaking traumatic
yes let's not add trauma on trauma you
know
building a house is for people that are
in a real healthy situation and
really excited about doing it and want
to do it you're
you're you're building out of necessity
or some kind of a grasping thing going
on here and it's
uh you know if your marriage isn't going
well and you want a divorce build a
house
you know that's that's that's the old
you know that's the truth because it'll
it's like you know
some people are so dumb they're like our
marriage isn't going good let's have
kids maybe that'll fix it you know
that's a dumb butt idea you know they do
that that'll break you real fast
that'll do it that'll end everything so
i think i'm just trying to love you
and say man if i were you i'd want to
curl up somewhere
in a snuggie and just get warm you know
you've been out in the cold it's
you're you're you're raw you know and
i'm i just man i want to if i was you
that's what i'd want to do
may i throw something else into the mix
quickly
my wife and i are here in maryland
taking care of her father
who's in stage four kidney failure
currently
three percent kidney function oh my gosh
so you know the line god keep
or god only give you as much as you can
handle
my line is he has us confused with
someone else
he took you right up to the line anyway
yeah so
you know it might be that you don't need
to make this decision right now
well trust me the insurance company and
the mortgage company
are hounding us have have you done your
repairs yet
yeah and okay well go ahead and turn it
back on them and go just write us a
check and we'll call it a day
so you know they have written the one
check and the mortgage company
has it but the mortgage companies paid
off
uh well they are holding the money in
trust
okay well tell the tell the uh insurance
company if they that you want to just
settle and if you don't have an attorney
you may need one
because you may need a buffer between
you and these characters right now
they're settling a whole bunch of claims
over there and i don't want you to get
stuck
yeah so you may need some representation
especially while you're dealing with
your father-in-law's illness
you're in a point of weakness there to
negotiate so yeah you do have your
you do have yourself full bob i'm sorry
wow